qué impacto ha tenido para méxico esta
decisión de la suprema corte muy buenas
tardes juani a toda la audiencia pues ha
sido un impacto
importante después de esta sentencia del
7 de septiembre de
2021 cinco estados en la república
decidieron reformar sus códigos penales
para despenalizar el aborto durante las
primeras 12 semanas de gestación lo cual
ha sido un avance importantísimo en
términos de regulación y además en
términos de precedentes jurídicos para
el país ahora hay muchas más
herramientas precisamente para aquellos
22 estados en donde continúa siendo
considerado un delito del aborto
voluntario pues se pueden avanzar en
este en este tipo de reformas cuando
hablamos de un país tan descentralizado
como méxico entonces a pesar de fallos
como estos depende finalmente de cada
estado avanzar en este tipo de medidas
exactamente el arreglo constitucional
mexicano al hacer o al ser un estado en
general
en el tema penal pues deja cada uno de
los estados la posibilidad
considerada el aborto como un delito o
no como ya lo tenemos en 10 entidades
federativas